so playing cops key okay final game
let's put this guy game on YouTube
regardless just one game
good luck cops can get a second game
he's my hero he's gonna play a London
Joe no ok playing let's play in this
mover
sometimes I play this suicide sure
I played cops key once and over the
board flips he crushed me in a row you
know I've seen constancies dreams but
he's not streaming right now I know his
his mouse skills are subpar but his
chest skills are amazing
stop playing me positionally
but maybe I can fight maybe i54 coming
mmm I forced my dear oh the lights
where's yeah I can teleport my queen
just some square let's take a pond
hamster camp
thanks for the bits yeah I messed up I
messed up man
let's go whoo I dropped a list up maybe
it doesn't matter not good
I'm scared I'm playing Eric it's Joaquin
I'm playing Eric oh my god
the people ah position see how fast he
is
sorry comes oh well he wants to draw oh
do I dirty five the legend he's a famous
legend strong okay Oh
feeding and he's the famous legend I had
to give him a draw yeah even though he's
winning but maybe he was also flagging
back anyway alright thank you
yeah